so you know listen where we live at okay
they've implemented a curfew for like
the third time where basically it means
nobody could be out after 8 p.m
and they're enforcing it they're giving
out large steep fines initially when
they put this thing out
even homeless people were not going to
be allowed to be outdoors it was crazy
you know covered up dropped they put out
all these vaccines
and all of a sudden the third wave is
coming now they're like we're going to
put back the curfew
shutting everything down it's been a
year guys it's been an officially a year
and so now preach i want to ask you what
are your thoughts on the latest curfew
the problem that i have is i don't have
any problem with any of the
rules and regulation that you install
that is okay that is all right
do you boo-boo by all means the problem
that i have with it
is the lack of the lack of consistency
you're gonna shut down the gyms you're
gonna shut down the beauty powers all of
that
good stuff the yoga places all of that
you're gonna you're gonna shut all of
that
the places that had no cases the
restaurant
the places that had no cases when you
were sitting in a restaurant you were
sitting you had plexi glass and
everything
no cases in restaurants right since
whenever we start
starting back and everything no cases in
the gym you're going to shut that down
but if you take public transportation
and i'm talking about the bus
nobody's two meters away nobody's two
meters away in the metro
what are you saying when you shop place
full of people
no two meters it's okay in the bus it's
okay at the supermarket but it's not
okay in the gym
when in the gym the point of the gym is
to go in
wash your hands then you go to your
place you wash your hands
then you do your exercise you wash the
machine
that was before kovid before kovid
you had to wash the place where you were
at
now with covet you know there's some
people that we're not doing before covet
i get you i get that and everything and
stuff
but now since kovit there's a little bit
of you know hey you know what if i don't
want this thing to shut down
and i had it at it for a long time i
need to clean up so the people
are cleaning their spots and people are
watching each other
clean their spot why are you shutting
everything down it's not even proven
it feels like you want to choose giant
science whenever you wanted to
science right oh you know what the
science shows that
we have to listen to science we have to
listen to science so there's a new wave
there's this that's happening there's
that oh science shows that the curfew
doesn't do anything ah
[ __ ] the science whatever the hell you
want to choose science you choose
science when you don't you don't it
makes
no sense you're inconsistent with your
stuff
it's crazy this is interesting on so
many levels my first problem
there's no scientific evidence to back
the fact that any of this works
no in fact in other countries where
they've not implemented any of these
curfews or
any of these hotel quarantines some of
their cases are comparable or even lower
even if you can
account for population size so i say
okay well if there's no science behind
it what is the point of this
and you realize that most aspects of
this pandemic and how they've handled it
have been super politicized meaning
they're doing things
for the next election cycle so they can
look like they're handling things well
but clearly from the vaccine robots they
haven't handled it well clearly from how
they've managed old people homes they
haven't handled it well
and they have the audacity to get on
night television all these times and say
it's your fault you didn't do enough you
know what the worst thing is and i'm
like [ __ ] you're the one who
compromises the old people's homes
you're the one who asked everybody who's
a business owner to
change the way they set up their
business to accommodate social distance
so people put money
into buying plexiglasses and all these
like crazy setups to accommodate you
and then what happened a couple weeks
later you still shut them down so you
ask them to invest all this money and
you still [ __ ] them over you constantly
talk about
social distancing all these other things
okay cool people jump on board with that
things don't go well it's somehow our
fault or maybe
or maybe hypothetical here maybe this is
too far gone
and all this posturing you're doing is
only making things worse you guys think
curfews
work because they say so there's zero
scientific evidence and they will say
this themselves
but they still impose it they expect you
to stay inside
compromise your mental health compromise
your physical health because this
pandemic has been terrible for people
physically in a lot of different ways
because of a practice that they're not
even sure works it goes even further
now they have hotel quarantines okay i
know tucker carlson called internment
camps i'm not gonna go that far but if
you leave the country and you come back
you have to pay two to three thousand
dollars to stay in a hotel for three
nights
get a bunch of tests at your own cost
before you can even be allowed to leave
and to go back to your home and to
quarantine there keep in mind
you can test negatives three days before
you leave right you have to test
you have to go get a test done before
you fly back home after you do this test
you fly you land you have to take
another test and you have to send the
hotel away
despite the fact that these hotels have
been fleecing people
not providing them with good food in
fact there's even violence that's been
recorded at these hotels
people don't expect people to do that
and i'm like who do you think this
affects the most
poor people who've got money like
whatever i'll stay wherever i want
that's not an issue
and here's how stupid it is these hotels
this rule only exists
at airports if you want to drive in you
don't have to go out of hotel quarantine
so what's the point of this rule
what are we doing right we're
implementing all this stuff why
from what it looks like on the outside
be honest with you guys
politics people want to get reelected
they can't afford to say we're not doing
enough because if people out of like
it's your fault so now they're going to
do
anything they'll put in whatever [ __ ]
rule that they saw someone else put in
to make it look like they're being tough
on safety
and then they're going to blame you the
public for the mistakes that they made
the audacity you know what uh go ahead i
want to play a video
but i'm asking that question can anybody
at phac table data
that shows that quarantining at a hotel
is better
from a public health perspective than
quarantining at somebody's house
could you table with committee the data
on adherence to quarantine for the last
year
[Music]
does that data exist mr chair we'd be
happy to
take that question back to the
department and bring forward information
with respect to um adherence to
quarantine measures that's available
thank you
was that data used in informing the
decision to make people quarantine at a
quarantine hotel which i note in the
main estimates
is going to cost a quarter of a billion
dollars so what data was used to inform
that decision
a quarter of a billion dollars what data
was used
anyone i mean it's just a quarter of a
billion dollars i mean what's that
between friends right
anyone any data
no thank you mr uncle garner 21 people
there
all elected officials people working for
the highest levels of government not a
single response
and that's where we're at today that's
where we're at today and
listen at some point we just gotta be
honest with ourselves
is the juice worth the squeeze what's
wrong with the juice
i'm off the boat i'm not squeezing the
juice i'm not i don't know what the
whatever
metaphor you want you lost me oh you
guys lost
a long ass time ago a long time ago but
i'm saying it publicly you know what the
thing is
we did this for a year i don't know what
it is a little bit longer get the
vaccine
okay at some point don't live their
lives yep okay and you're not gonna like
it for me but guess what
i'm not i'm just the person saying it
the folks out there believe it
so you guys can have whatever opinion
you want about me i'll take that
yep but out there that's what they're
thinking they don't see the logic and if
you ask and you pull people
are they happy with the response a lot
of them like i don't know a lot of them
are going to feel that way
so that's my thoughts process a lot of
problems that happen in the health
system here
the worst part of that in 2002 the
person that was in charge of the health
department was the prime minister that
we had now so all the problems that we
have with the health
system he could have done something back
then but
it wasn't done it was not done so you
saw this thing coming this
train wreck come you didn't do you
didn't do nothing
you know come on now and i get it people
are afraid people want to be safe
but just because you're afraid and safe
doesn't mean taking any form of action
is better than inaction
and at some point i would argue a lot of
these messages that we've taken
are hurting us more than they're helping
us definitely okay there's gonna be a
huge
physical monetary mantle right that
we're gonna have to pay
we're gonna have to pay that price and
if people are gonna look back and say
this was worth it i'm gonna
i'm gonna disagree in them that's just
my thought process on it this is like
vietnam
what you mean they went in they made
everybody
believe that we won the war that that
america won the war yeah we're gonna win
yeah and afterwards yeah yeah afterwards
afterwards later on
when the reports came out you know yeah
it was pretty bad you know
we this is what it is yeah what it is
that's my thought process on it you know
you guys have failed and you've eroded
public trust so that's my thought
process on on all this on this whole
topic
that's what i think i'm over it i'm not
gonna lie man america's freedom sound
really great right now
anything else you want to add man the
amount of people have lost their
businesses people
lost their minds in this thing calling
people crazy for opening up and now
look at them they're not so crazy now
[Music]
me